hi there and welcome to this week's
Android developer office hours one day
late but brought to you from the usual
place in our studio in London today I'm
rich Timon I'm always and I'm joined by
winner Chris Bane's so the reason that
yesterday is because Chris as we were
discussing roadmap stuff that's not been
pronounced but we will be talking about
Android development topics thank you to
all the people in the Hangout have
joined us today
that's quite a quick introduction yeah
there we go
someone's joined us we are now
officially live we have a viewer but as
usual we priority prioritizing questions
asked in the moderator beforehand
there's Andrew Kelly just to watch all
this questions come true so other things
that have happened this week
Mobile will Congrats on this week over
in Barcelona HTC announced the one means
the HTC One X is now the X HTC One the
AC one is the new okay but it does look
nice previously I heard about 5-inch
1080p screens and thought maybe point
seven inch 1080p screen and I really
trust HTC for their screen quality as
well from the One X and other devices
the screens are pretty awesome yeah
their device quality so the hardware
quality's always been very oh my god
someone's discovered metal as well I'm
like it's an Android manufacturer making
a device out of metal so I'm quite
excited to go and see the HTC One at
some point I haven't got my hands on yet
but hopefully they'll be anyone know the
shipping date no I'm quite a people
would say my first are to be trying to
call Google and a whole load of 5-inch
1080p phones yeah then 45 snowy feet
which I'm sure some screen manufacturers
doing trade I could trade in those
Google Play services we had an update to
that this week a major update to Google
Play services now where you have your
Google+ sign-in and I know a chance to
look through the
I've seen the Google Play services demo
from the the plus team that they're
doing and it seems pretty simple you can
just
requesting authentication details comes
up with a nice white dialogue saying
this use of the bike access to your
River
I realize this coolness there's a BBS
put it on your website saying installed
they have like one click so that is
really nice here that's button that we
have in the Play Store the install
button if they're logged in is if
they're logged into Google+ if I looked
into chrome just a Google+ if you got a
session like that install button will
work on your website he just be a
straight into the Android device that is
code for a lot of linking is quite cool
as well so you can share links and maps
code updates as well maps v2 got some
updates as well maybe fixes there's a
list of those changes available via plus
Android developers and if they are
supriya before we um Nix supporters
spoiling it new device oh yeah this is
now the Crowell office brought to you by
Nick in his picture okay fantastic
unless Andrew cases evening unless
anyone in the Hangout as a question for
us will dive straight into that
moderator for people on the UM where
somebody is having a hard problem when
he calls the message Sarah's horizontal
list on four point one actually I think
this should not happen but please
provide us with more information maybe
you're my first maybe some code we need
more information to come back at you but
it looks like it should work on 4.0 and
4.2 has anyone used UI Automator you
that's somewhat to-do-list played around
a little bit it's actually quite nice
but I think this should really work on
four point one I see no why there should
be a restriction on 14.1 when it's
working on four point two so I think
this is send us more information and
we'll try to yeah from the best part
rise a book on beta Andrew calm to
Android to come okay
yeah help you on there yeah sorry so
yeah we have another question regarding
how you can identify your users there
actually was a blog post from Tim Bray
like one year ago I think you you're
good off if you're just going in there
and look what he suggests basically what
he's saying is to create a user ID on
the application install the application
just basically created UUID and maintain
this UID of course you will also see
that he will refer to using things like
you mentioned like secure Android ie
calling get device ID
I mean other things but those have major
drawbacks but just look at the post and
I think you will find the best solution
for your requirement
if people wonder why I keep looking down
on take me away again we're indexing
this week's show again so I'm just
putting a little Oh next week so in
YouTube comments later on the YouTube
video makes more sense people flip
through to the the most appropriate part
see I've got a question from kitesurfer
who asks how can i style an imageview
globally from his fame his application
fee my designer wants his margins
everywhere how do I do this easily well
there's no sort of built-in standard way
to do this and a lot ListView which has
this new style in its the theme that the
global theme so you can have to do it
yourself basically so you can either
create a style and then use that sort of
reference that style or XML or away
quickly I for doing it was to create a
custom you
and then overload the constructor to
always pass in your style so yeah that's
pretty the quickest way of doing it but
there's no built-in framework why if you
wanted one startup imagery across
qualification it makes no sense - yeah
yeah have you run out but there is not
there is no definition in a theme and
you can then kind of refer to a parent
absolute so you have to do it like Chris
just suggested if you go all the way and
then have some custom attributes inside
your passing you could do any tricks
much we wrote a blog post about let's
run a blog post but it closed last week
so just check kiku up dot blog spot.com
for more information well plus
retirement hi we've had some more people
join us in the chat since then we've got
a dog and Giuseppe going to bed
thank you for joining us one day late
apologies for the staffing issues that
led to this one yesterday here's the dog
there as well guys I have a to technical
question okay
well the first one is that in my Eclipse
IDE disappear from the Google menu add
the net evil support anyone had the
experience about that
so if support is using the using the ADT
right of Android in Eclipse it you have
a menu when you click right on the your
project then you have a good Android
menu and then add native support okay
from my menu is a disappeared I don't
have any more for few project not for
everyone really well I don't have a
coding machine stay here with me
unfortunately but I don't even know the
native support option did and yeah there
is there is there is not to support that
ad before you the C++ support John you
wonder if that only happens if you've
got the C++ extension installed in
circlips
version 21 revision 2 everything worked
well I have many application with the
native support but starting this is a 21
update that the tour release last week
then there is this problem now I just
asked if someone have the same problem
so that is not I will find in my search
or I will write some email to tour
director sure Yossi can you replicate
that same issue just out of interest so
you know I just shifted did you set the
NDK path for the yes everything
everything just dissipated yeah this
disappears just disappeared from the
menu and when I'm disappeared
disappeared just for few projects for
example in my left side I have a 20
project then of Danny I have this menu
and other 10 there is no booth
very strange and I don't know why I
don't know why starting the diesel
update the strict mode the strict mode
start start to throw exception strange
accent exception on CL database open say
that the database is open when this is
not true hmm yes if you are the strict
mode and then you try to close your push
sort then the database and then the
connection you will see that strict mode
will throw an exception yes leader this
didn't happen before you use to the same
to the second issue you're using begin
transaction and end transaction yes on
all the database methods no it's strict
Marion framework isn't it so the
operator if you'll the oil supplier of
Management let me to let me confirm
again that this happened only starting
the revision 21 over the ADT on the 20
on the 20 disk don't happened
this shouldn't be part of ADT where the
strict light is nothing to do with this
remote I know I know - are you having
the issue on all devices that you tested
on or just one or two devices no all
devices if I open a simple connection
then I open a cursor I read that the
cursor close the cursor close the
connection close the database then
change the activity and then destroy
objection very simple code for a few
lines how much exception is it it's
trade you are closing an activity that
to have an open connection with database
something like that across
hmm okay have you tried using
cursorloader no no no no I didn't try I
just ride with the standard mode just
open the cursor just using a simple seat
well Alper
nothing I wonder how strict mode is
tracking that whether it's waiting for
the garbage collection to clear up the
database before it realizes that the
activity no longer has it open I don't
know what what strict mode is using the
problem of the garbage collector was
when you use it provider when you who
use the provider to connect to the
database then you don't have to close
any course or you don't have to close
because the provider take checking
charge to close everything but in the
case of a simple code you open the
connection you open the hood you close
it and then why this fixed mode that is
a head trolling with this exception
there's no other you are in the Android
2.3 these don't happen in the starting
Android 4.2 to this happen I didn't to
try to with the ice cream I will try but
when I came to you gingerbread know he's
offline
not this time not this time interesting
that that was the first the first time
question then that is also a second
question any way to use downloaded
downloaded the native library and a load
eat from a simple folder and the not
from a data folder no that I know if you
can checks that can fly for that one
yeah there there's there's a next class
loader mm-hmm so he can you can fetch a
jar and you can with the text class
loader I can
the Java library and I'm talking about
the s all not very native library no I
know what you're trying to do inside
your application I don't know how we're
doing it
mm-hmm you could use a another Android
application for the same user ID and
then the user has to install that extra
I would like to ask you for you can we
become again that the answer those I
lost the courageous so this is how most
video players work on the market where
you have the video player and then I get
over sort of plugins you can install
which if you cpu specific binaries so
you can create another application yeah
the loser will have to application that
case oh yeah this is the solution
yeah but show to me uses my application
and my application codec codec one codec
- it's not very good for for the user
you know yeah the episode it's called if
the security hole if you can just
download execute yeah because it because
I think that I can't think of a way to
do it or not not from not the data
directory family because there is a one
of our application that use some some
codec for special things but not all of
the users need it the codec weight is up
works 10 megabyte for each processor so
if I wanted to take care of everybody
everybody must have an application large
50 megabytes and it's not good so if you
need the function then you download the
codec but I was fine in some way to
don't download a new package a new
applicate just looking if I can download
myself unzip to the file and then a load
to using the system load for example but
I tried it myself there is no way
because say that the
mounted for no execution correct correct
okay because the thing is when you
install the application the framework
I've done I've got covering the exactly
specifically but links against the
system libraries and it doesn't a lot
specific stuff with and so if you if the
sort of the libraries your linked
against the difference the ones that run
the device it will do some special stuff
I'll cover in these specifics so yeah I
mean it's all tied in to install
applications so the framework needs to
do stuff and so you can't be just
download library no know what personally
this is my opinion and the letter I
leave the space held awhile other people
to speak my opinion is that it's a very
bad to see that application that user
root root system they are able to write
in the data folder they are able to load
from data folder this library better
that they have contact logic better than
an application that not use given of
course there's a lot of things that
route access would make a lot easier for
you but it's all oh it was security yeah
okay we don't actually have answers for
those questions right now though I'm
sorry Giuseppe hopefully uh keeping the
tools team you'll find out some of the
answers so it's quite a lot going on the
window there is I can't read any of the
chat know we know what so we can jump
into and then I'll take one from the G+
stream Linden disaster in the comments
Linda darling asks how does he get into
Android so that's Jerry as a result of
going through the app clinic and Android
design in action process so they're
Trello is the way to go there so yeah I
do suggest you topics if your app does
influence one of the topics or if it is
Florence one of the topics already
suggested then yeah propose itself more
makeup and make it clear that you are
the developer own yourself dominating
because we do we do Toni prefer those I
think the bitly link is broken to can't
go to Biglia slash at the neck trailer
anymore but he just Google for
Android app to Nick Trello I thinks it's
festive well I might have to do that
myself
I want to be pure Android straining to
read that that bar outside actually
talking about that someone's put in the
comments they'd like to know why we went
from our service food to a custom view
on the ultimate stopwatch and what the
performance benefits were we did it
generally the surface views on Android
have always been a hole-punch through
your UI layers and then rendered on the
very top as a canvas and just they've
never been hardware accelerated so if
you were using surface use you've got a
lot of flexibility but you missed out on
all the hotness that was introduced with
the hardware acceleration through three
four and 4.4.2 so it actually didn't
take long at all
I've been putting off for ages but it
didn't take longer talking to convert
from a surface view to a custom view and
now I've done a whole load of
benchmarking on it and frame retrials
have gone down from like 45 milliseconds
to one millisecond there so there's
other things in the way I'm using the
vsync has suggested by cyril he chimed
in saying i should usually sync i think
it was
so it's limiting it's 60 frames a second
then it easily manages it with the
hardware acceleration but even on not
hardware accelerated devices because a
whole load of new tools become available
to you once you're doing hardware
accelerated rendering but will the GPU
profiling tools and that sort of thing
I've managed to optimize it so it's a
lot faster even as a custom view on
gingerbread than it was on the East
Racer I didn't use I'm not using OpenGL
but would it trace anyway now I just use
the tools inside developer options on
here turning on over draws and that's
something in CP profiling on over draws
yeah and it turned out that I had a
white background on my view pager that
was being drawn every frame which you
couldn't see and there's another one
else it's being drawn every frame and I
took a few of those out and it hath the
regional times everything turned green
of everything it's very helpful to use
two useless tools because you can easily
optimize because sometimes it's just see
the that you have to read through every
single line of code run optimize so in
the Jamie asks if he hasn't had the
distributed via email and will his stats
appear the developer console for an arse
and so forth
I don't know right I think if you have
it if it if you have that package name
reserved from the developer console you
will still get it and matter where they
install it from where you have to have
it first yeah if there's a listing for
that package did you see it on the cheap
so using that strength way inside of a
viewpager causes black rectangles to be
left when paging a bit like sharing and
any tips to avoid this well this is same
thing that's what rich was on about
earlier and maps a she uses surface view
so again it's a sort of view print area
back of the window and so there isn't
really many tips you can do you can kind
of display a view over the top and kind
of block the flash so it's not so
visually obvious and that's just the way
it is kind of thing and if you're having
a map view in a view pager you haven't
you've got to horizontally scrolling
items anyway so I'd be careful so yeah
basically this not machine do such you
can't even hide it but you can't really
fix it yeah there's a question in the
charge Lee Claude Claudio as ice-t
having examples of doing facial
recognition ha yes yeah we have a facial
recognition the sample somewhere pulls
out eyes nose mouth stuff to find facial
recognition actually it will it will
tell you that there's faces in the
picture and how many faces and where the
various points on those faces are what
it won't do is say that it's Chris bones
or Stefan in snow or whatever you have
to do that bit with your own eyes so by
social recognition do you mean the fact
that those faces there or actually who
the faces are face recognition or facial
recognition
probably the latter in which case no I
don't I'm waiting for some places it the
class is called phase detector but there
are a few caveats to it in the it only
supports bitmaps and the only supports
bitmaps in the format RGB 565 it does
not support 8/8 doesn't do the effort
yeah just wait that's all it's about a
year in the comments right oh is the map
view is scroll lock face kg zoom in on
this thing on side that was easy okay I
see the icon 300s decay management when
I click it nothing happens open up a
command window depending if you're on
Mac or PC open up a command or a command
show and run it and see what the
exception that's coming at ya okay on a
Mac just open up your shell find your
SDK I go into the tools directory and
run Android and you'll see the exception
that's coming out was it's being run you
probably can't find Java or something
crazy no exception it just nothing
happens at all buy a new Mac can you
guys hear me yeah sorry
so no actually it runs so the monitor
the Android saw the so when I run it the
the monitor comes up but I only see the
device tab so when you run up the
monitor you can look and see the device
tab but then there should be also a
device about the different Android SDKs
that you can install yes
I sounds like you're running a device
monitor no and the Android oh so I'm
just running the wrong monitor there's
an executable just called Android yeah
you just need to run that okay so i'll
launch that from from the terminal
thanks yeah try that okay okay if that
doesn't work they make sure you have the
latest version of the ADT tools as well
you can download packaged up or not I
think you'll need the latest version for
jellybean devices anyway we've had that
question a few times I've reviewed jelly
bean device into your your computer and
you run
maybe be and it says it's offline that's
just because you need the latest version
of ADT tools where the secure ADB is
included and the next time you run ADB
devices you'll see on your screen it
says will you allow debugging from this
hex code computer and when you say yes
then it switches from offline to online
so if you do see that in ADB just make
sure you've got the latest tools from
tools.android.com perfect thanks okay
Claudio's put I can detect a face but
not which store information of a face
recognition so you're trying to detect
individual faces as if people rather
than faces a set or any detects by
detects always that's the main thing
attacks yeah very handy for putting
glasses on pictures of people I detect a
face but not which store information for
face recognition so I still don't stand
Fabio if you Peter
one more shot elaboration we'll have
another go it's a few online services
about all that so are for OPI is that
you can do this kind of stuff face comm
this one I've suffered that's for what
Andrew Kelly something oh yeah ok last
three minutes my devices died sir
devices take my camera any thoughts
about the background horrible defining
the minimum size of use is that what you
want to happen
he thought new but you could make it put
an image view inside a layout and then
wrap everything's that content and at
least the whole layout would be minimum
size of the image and then you could
import that into another layer if you
wanted layout hierarchy madness they
track but they're no is he trying to say
that he doesn't want it to be a minimum
size or of course you can use min width
in min height on the view and just give
it the number of DPS or even pixels that
the image is if you really wanted to
that schedule this hangout is great does
it happen every week yes happens every
week on Wednesdays except when it's on
Thursday that's quite rare it's always
on Wednesdays can I have a quick
question yeah you see what do you think
about implementing have a list of let's
say items that I have more than I want
to show the user a couple of quick
actions on the same row for each item
but I need to have two more actions to
the which list on each item on the list
so basically I have four actions but two
of them should be quick actions so I'll
do a custom view with added buttons or
something and what do you think should
be the implementation or the UI for
having an interaction for two more
actions I thought about the long press
but not sure that's the proper because I
have actions on the view so what's your
suggestion you can do context action by
long-pressing contextual action bar just
don't do a pop-up dialog
there's lots thinking Oh an alternative
if you can look at something like the
cards in Google now they have like a
small version of the overflow button
which leads to additional actions or so
another music app the same similar with
a drop down the little disclosure arrow
which you could you know normally used
to spin it to do that to show a pop-up
menu that could work as well okay so the
overflow button from Google now could be
on each on each item on the list yeah
all the disclosure triangle thing just I
prefer the triangle yeah
yeah me too actually and being ever feel
about a contextual action bar because if
it is contextual actions mean that's
what it's there for it also it means if
you can perform that action on multiple
items you kind of get that behavior for
free with the context action mind
annotation which ever you like yeah and
that's what I thought because I'm I'm
trying to merge several actions to be
more to be more specific
I wanted to use the split action bar to
show quick actions that are changed
contextual a way when you long-haul then
when you don't have the long press edit
mode and I wasn't sure if I can maybe
show that button or should I use the
contextual menu so i i i thought of a
lot of suggestions i wasn't sure which
ones to implement
yeah I like sunny protection action bar
or some type drop-down affordance oh
yeah yeah just don't do single click to
open protection but that's Ari no no no
wouldn't do anything no went no matter
what Nick did clarify that he actually
wanted to the background image not to
specify the minimum size so if you've
got a 100 by 20 text view and the image
is wanted by 100 the text view will grow
so you could use 9-patch images
something like that or your own custom
version of text view yeah extend text
for you but I would say go with the
9-patch if you can and then just define
the scaling areas in the content areas
so that you actually have some
consistency over what the background
image will be otherwise you're not going
to know I mean the system is not just
gonna make a guess at which part of the
image you want to show also quick
shout-out to the Berlin GDG why not if
you're an Android developer and you want
some help locally then go to your local
Google developer group because they all
have similar interests and there's a
London Android user group here in Berlin
there's the billion GDG they're all over
the place and you can find them by
searching for GDG on on Google
everything else we finish yeah you're
coming in there the next one here to the
convention in Israel sorry Yossi are you
coming to the convention in Israel next
week yes Nick and I might be in Israel
for Monday and Tuesday next week yeah
cool see you there yeah I'm lecturing
excellent all right
I'll share the podium with you thanks
everyone
we'll catch you again next week see you
guys thanks